this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 11 with Echo Charles and me Jocko
willink good evening Echo good evening
we have some more q a
for today from
the underground the underground yes sir
so people that are in the underground
know how to ask questions to the
underground
more
uh narrow audience so we get to them
quicker so here we go uh here's a
question and this question is actually
directed
I believe at Echo Charles for the most
part so I'm gonna read it it says I've
been lifting weight bodybuilding
powerlifting since high school I
recently purchased Jocko's Field Manual
it was an all it was awesome by the way
so the thing is I'm not very familiar
with the Olympic lifts and I can't
afford to do BJJ and Crossfit obviously
I'm going with BJJ because you can't
Burpee out of a Chokehold
I'm curious to what movements Echo
Charles bases his lifting around I know
he played D1 football so he may be more
familiar with Olympic lifts as well I'm
just trying to see what weight training
split will complement a beginner at BJJ
and someone who isn't very familiar with
Olympic lifts
I'm very experienced with the big three
squat bench deadlift but I love cardio
the cardio aspect that comes with metcon
Olympic lifting Echo Charles
go okay let me preface this with my I'll
be back in 15. personal
my personal training certificate
certification is expired has been did
you actually get one out about a
certification it was like one of the
bare minimum win ones
2003 were you thinking maybe that was
the road that wasn't that was the road
dad did you actually do that for a while
I was a personal trainer for a little
while yes oh wow a year and a half one
year where I don't know 24-Hour Fitness
San Diego yeah San Diego UTC 24 Hour
Fitness yep no okay it's true well in
college I went to school for I wanted to
be a strength conditioning coach so that
was what I sort of pursued that's why
um so you're a your bro science has a
little some regular science in it yes
yeah you could have fooled me over the
past 10 years you know well in exercise
and like sports
um bro Sciences
in the exercise at sports bro
no yeah there's so much updating you
know because Eric you know everybody's
body's different and all this stuff
responds differently different things
it's fast switch slow twitch muscles
like media switch which is a thing yeah
see and even that you know it's like put
it this way there's always new updates
to it so things that we thought was the
best way okay sometimes later on they
found out hey that's not the best way
this is even better way science some
things they say hey this is not even
true anymore because we thought it was
true because of this this but this this
is only the case because of this other
thing that we didn't know about well
lately there's been a lot of a lot of
this trust the science stuff going
around yeah and the thing about truck
like you just said you can trust science
today it could be different tomorrow
yeah and then even that that's going to
depend because there's like what do you
call them the hard sciences and then
there's the not hard scientists or
whatever yeah so then there's that going
on even in the hard Sciences like things
get proven wrong over time yeah and I
think
like there are
yeah I mean at the end of the day yeah
but
there's no a lot of stuff but yes there
is a butt they're not gonna prove that
one plus one like for some reason
doesn't equal two anymore it's like that
kind of stuff you know it's math yeah
which is one of the hard science
Sciences or it's part of the hearts and
I'm not no I'm not this is absolutely
true either way back to lifting let's
see let's focus on them yeah let's get
back okay the hard side the hard Bro
Science of lifting hard science of
lifting all right
um this is my opinion and it it's not
like gonna be I am not a strength and
conditioning coach at all okay but if
you ask me what I do and what I've found
to be beneficial for jiu jitsu and
non-ju Jitsu stuff here's what I what I
have currently so I don't my workouts
are not based for jiu jitsu not fully
some of it is because lifting weights
has all kinds of different Pursuits you
want muscular endurance you want to look
good you want big muscles you want to be
strong you want it to be Performance
Based and then Performance Based how you
know like you want to be strong in the
weight room you want to be fast you want
to you know so there's like all all
kinds of different Pursuits going in
different directions fully
so mine was when I started lifting
weights it was to be quote unquote big
and strong and fast okay which are three
different things too by the way but my
workouts would be based kinda with those
three interest in mind are they still
not the fast so I think he's asking what
are you doing right now yeah
um but I think that that's important to
preface because it's like oh wait I
don't clapping myself
if they have the same question they
think that this is beneficial because it
is and this is why because sometimes
people will be like hey they'll like
look at me and I'll get this they'll be
like hey what do you do for lifting but
then if you don't say like well my I
don't do this thing and then I happen to
get this result it's like I have these
certain things that I do for working out
that for these certain results or
whatever and they conflict with each
other like a lot of the lists that I do
totally conflict with Jiu Jitsu like as
far as I mean I guess they'd be
considered like bodybuilding lifts like
just the format you know like if if I do
five sets of 12
reps we'll say shoulder press
if I said to 12 reps uh a minute minute
and a half rest in between till failure
every time that's a bodybuilding type
movement that's not directly beneficial
to jiu jitsu
okay in fact if you put on lean muscle
mass that's not effective for jiu jitsu
to a certain point
so if you're a two super skinny little
dude and then you put on muscle mass
okay but once you get sort of into that
a certain range depending on your body
build or whatever the muscle works
against you in jiu jitsu
okay oh yeah it does wait wasn't it you
that was saying oh yeah you put it you
want to get up to like 250. yeah yeah
just say that on the podcast yes and
then uh and then I went to Ron right I
ran four miles and I was like good I'm
too big this is too much and the thing
is you could be 250 good weight or bad
weight you'd probably have that same
thing going on if you don't train for
running the mile you see what I'm saying
if I was training
then I wouldn't have been able to get to
250. if I've been if I kept running well
it would have been just a lot harder
yeah and arguably yeah you couldn't have
you know yeah oh it's possible yeah so
have you ever heard that in an obese
person cannot do a pull-up have you ever
heard that
no I heard well I heard it I think it
was talking about kids it was like
another person saying because I'm a big
uh proponent of pull-ups and there's
some fact or something that I read in
the in the uh Manual of Bro Science I
guess sure but I said an obese kid
cannot do a pull-up so if you if you get
your kids doing pull-ups and they keep
doing pull-ups you're gonna be they're
gonna be
in better shape yeah but okay so even
that that barely well then again that's
unclear because so because a fat kid can
do a pull-up I mean not all of them of
course but that's what I'm saying I'm
not sure about that yeah that's what I'm
saying but if if what you're saying is
whoever said that or whatever what they
meant was if you can do a pull-up we
cannot consider you obese no matter how
fat you are right even though that's not
the definition of being obese by the way
I think the idea was in order to be able
to do a pull-up
if your body weight goes over a certain
amount there's no way that your strength
ratio can support it oh like that type
of thing yeah that doesn't sound right
but I I don't know obviously because
pull-ups is how strong your arms and
your back is yeah really but I'm saying
there's a certain limit to how strong
your arms and back can be with kids I
guess because with adults I see guys
doing pull-ups with all kinds of Weights
chapter things so you get a guy with
that kind of strength and then they got
a hundred pounds 100 pounds of body fat
and they can do pull-ups they can still
be obese okay so it's like different you
know let's see Bro Science was just
maybe proven wrong
I don't know if we solved anything we
just asked a bunch of questions with you
know all right I am going to really try
and be quiet so you can get through this
okay so anyway so what I do is actually
pretty simple I have three days of
essentially the same thing as far as
lifting weights goes
which is like a I'd say they're they're
geared towards bodybuilding they're real
basic like four sets of 12 of shoulder
press and then three sets of 12 of
lateral raises with shrugs as it's like
a what do you call it like a superset
there's a difference between super
sudden giant set I forget what it is one
is doing the same body part with two
exercises and one essential set and the
other one is doing two different body
parts right after you know anyway so I
go because that reason shrugs that's a
that's a superset
do three sets of that that's for
shoulders and then go to like bicep
curls three four sets of that same thing
12 reps twelve depends on the day so if
I did 12 reps last time I did it I'll go
down to like a five six seven maybe
eight kind of situation and I alternate
so that's a one day and then the other
day is squats
like a same thing four sets of twelve or
five or whatever
um and then the other day is a like
bench but I do dumbbells bench or
incline and then Rose and Pull-Ups and
you're you most of the time you're
working either 12 rep range or five rep
range
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you
huge assistance at Jocko underground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you mobilized
Underground